[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique nous allons essayer de
comprendre aujourd'hui pourquoi une
partie des français veulent bloquer le
pays
le samedi 17 novembre pour protester
contre le prix des carburants est on
dans une nouvelle révolte populiste ou
une réaction aux premières mesures
contraignantes contre le réchauffement
climatique
est-ce que symptôme d'un vrai malaise
d'un fossé entre les villes et les
campagnes où entre les riches et les
pauvres
pour en débattre sur ce plateau avec
nous vincent guinet bonjour bonjour vous
avez dansé avec d'autres un appel à la
manifestation du 17 en côte d'or vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi
claire mallard bonjour monsieur vous
êtes co secrétaire régional d'europe
écologie les verts il ya dans ce dossier
bien sûr une dimension écologique et
climatique
vincent martin bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le président de la fédération des
travaux publics de bourgogne franche
comté des professionnels très inquiet
aussi de cette hausse et des projets sur
leur gasoil spécifiques et réunir des
robes bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
la république en marche de
saône-et-loire dans une circonscription
rurale en partie où vous devez avoir
quelques retours des électeurs on va en
parler alors la question est simple
pourquoi il ya déjà eu des flambées de
prix des carburants ya même eu dans le
passé certains carburant plus cher
qu'est ce qui vous motive un sanguinet
pourquoi vous vous lancer là dedans
la raison est simple c'est tout d'abord
à une atteinte au pouvoir d'achat
je pense que les français en ont
ras-le-bol clairement là on est
dépendant notre nos véhicules pour aller
travailler
malheureusement n'existe pas forcément
d'alternative aujourd'hui et toutes ces
taxes mis bout-à-bout font que
les français ont de plus en plus de mal
à s'en sortir on va y venir bien sûr et
sur les impôts et sur l'alternative
quand on vous fait remarquer que
l'extrême droite par exemple était déjà
très présente dans les défilés autour
des 80 km heure on les sent très
présents sur ce mouvement aussi est-ce
que ça vous gêne est ce que vous essayez
de vous en vous en écarter de cette
politisation possible alors la chose à
retenir c'est que c'est un mouvement
complètement citoyen est un politique
justement donc aucun parti politique
quel qu'il soit c'est juste l'union des
citoyens qui fait qui fait la force dans
cette manifestation venir à vérone
est-ce que c'est inattendu ou est ce que
les élus ruraux que vous êtes avez vous
est-ce que vous avez vu le coup venir
est ce que vous avez senti monter cette
colère oui et non parce que il y a eu
déjà des flambées vous l'avez dit de
prix sur le carburant et qu'à chaque
fois c'est difficile pour chacun d'entre
nous même si nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une période où il y à des
améliorations sur le pouvoir d'achat
hausse du salaire net
taxe d'habitation divisé par trois par
une partie de nos concitoyens donc il y
a véritablement des acquis en terme de
pouvoir d'achat donc on pouvait penser
que les choses l'amortissement se ferait
un peu mieux mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours désagréable quand il y à une
eau je rappelle que ces 75 % de la
hausse en question qui est celle en fait
de la hausse du prix des carburants
les taxes de représentants chrétiens
mais en baisse depuis quelques jours et
en plus les cargaisons des données
donc si ça se trouve le 17 novembre on
aura déjà bien amorcé les padres à l'est
par la sas l'émission question de la fin
d'émission la saint martin on a un
gouvernement qui toute la gauche
reproche d'en faire trop pour les
entreprises donc est ce que il ya quand
même pas beaucoup de dettes d'un côté
qui font que tout ça n'est pas forcément
si grave bien comme le dit rémy
rebeyrotte c'est nous sommes habitués à
la hausse du carburant
c'est certain nous avons
nous sommes sur le pour le domaine des
travaux publics nous sommes impactés sur
le gasoil non routier puisque nous
utilisons du gasoil spécifique pour nos
engins de chantier et nous subissons
cette mesure fiscale qui est consiste à
des tac au tac c'est justement le taxer
taxer à nouveau le gasoil sur pour
l'utilisation dans nos engins de
chantier et ça fait des coups sans
compensation des coûts considérables à
savoir ça vient impacter nos résultats
d'exploitation et puis ça viendra impact
est également la marche de nos
entreprises les emplois et les
investissements puisque nous étions bien
partis depuis quelques mois sur un
avenir effectivement à la fois sur la
dimension pouvoir d'achat sur la
dimension des conséquences économiques
ferme à l'art est ce qu'on est face pour
la première fois on va dire au premier
bras de fer sur une mesure écologique
contraignantes
écoutez nous ce qu'on pense on pense
qu'il ya une vraie une vraie comment va
comment on va le dire comment on va dire
il ya une vraie injustice en fait car on
ne taxe pas les principaux pôles heures
aujourd'hui que sont le transport
routier le transport aérien et le
transport ferroviaire
aujourd'hui la niche fiscale sur le
kérosène c'est 3,5 milliards d'euros par
an de manque de manque à gagner pour
l'état met donc ça veut dire il y à
augmenter le prix du diesel c'est pas
une bonne idée
c'était demandé bien sûr il faut
absolument en fait taxées avoir une
fiscalité écologique pour faire face au
défi climatique
on en est bien conscient mais cette
fiscalité écologique doit être redonner
aux français pour qu'elle soit investie
dans la transition écologique et surtout
qu'on applique le principe pollueur
payeur et le principe de justice sociale
pour que tout le monde contribue à la
lutte contre le changement climatique
notamment ceux qui polluent le plus et
qui sont aujourd'hui exonérés de taxes
alors à sanguinet vous avez parlé de
pouvoir d'achat tout à l'heure rémy
rebeyrotte vous dis oui mais on a fait
des efforts pour pouvoir d'achat vous
l'entendez où vous avez l'impression
plutôt qu on vous reprend d'un côté ce
qu'on vous a redonné de l'autre en fait
j'entends surtout que on
vous donne quelque chose la main droite
et on nous le reprend très rapidement de
la main gauche
mais est-ce que c'est nouveau en quoi
est-ce que ça motive de bloquer le pays
le 17 c'est pas tellement nouveau les
impôts dans ce pays on sait que le taux
d'imposition il est très élevé en france
par rapport à beaucoup plus je pense que
le le troupeau de moutons a assez suivi
le berger est aujourd'hui les français
en ont vraiment marre on vit tous dans
une une situation à regarder ce qu'on a
dans notre frigo pour ma part par
exemple le plein de carburant
quand je fais le plein de son véhicule
c'est 20 euros de plus clairement
j'en fais trois ça fait 60 euros 60
euros pour moi je préférais les remettre
dans un restaurant de mon village ou
bien emmener les enfants au cinéma ou
autre tout ça je peux pas le faire donc
l'écologie c'est un point jus on est
d'accord pour le tout ce qui est du
climat mais ce n'est pas en nous prenant
1 euro 50 voire 60
en fait c'est pour vous faire arrêter de
rouler avec du diesel aux émissions
roule c'est pour aller au boulot je vois
pas beaucoup de monde qui roule comme ça
pour se promener quoi je dors mal à y
répondre des pyrénées à beyrouth oui je
veux répondre
il ya vraiment deux impératifs dans le
cadre de la lutte majeure contre les
changements climatiques pour
l'amélioration de la qualité de l'air on
a vraiment besoin de cette fiscalité
écologique mais elle doit être redonner
aux français pour qu'ils aient plus de
transports en commun et moins chers et
qu'ils puissent aussi changer de
véhicule et acquérir des véhicules
qu'ils soient moins polluants chaque
euro collecté doit être heureuse
redistribue aux français dans la
transition écologique je crois que le
message il est la première verra ce que
les français comprennent c'est qu'en
fait on leur dit que c'est un impôt
écologique puis en réalité c'est une
façon de remplir les caisses de l'état
des jeux je peux comprendre certaines
choses
2010on à une flambée du prix des
carburants
déjà largement due à l'augmentation tout
simplement des prix du pétrole
j'ai relu les débats de l'époque un
certain nombre de politiques disent donc
faut qu'on soit moins dépendant du
pétrole moins dépendant des énergies
fossiles
il faut s'y mettre je constate qu'en
2018 ont scié peux me on a pendant cette
période favoriser le diesel dont on fait
semblant de s'apercevoir aujourd'hui les
particules fines c'est pas mieux poc
les sens et qu'au bout du compte on un
véritable problème à la fois climatique
et puis en termes également médical
d'allergies de monter en puissance
les allergies etc et donc nous
l'engagement qu'on a pris par contre
c'est d'accélérer aujourd'hui le passage
à une autre économie et à une autre
logique sur le plan des carburants et
notamment la voiture hybride la voiture
électrique les autres mobilité il nous
mène il a dit vincent guinée il a dit
oui mais le béton 34 milliards de l'ama
d'autres solutions pour l'instant nous
mettons 34 milliards d'euros
donc il faut de la fiscalité pour ça oui
34 milliards d'euros sur la transition
écologique dans le prochain budget
national on ne peut plus aujourd'hui
tergiverser on peut plus seulement par
les foi juive elle trépigne terme à la
relation effectivement je trépigne parce
que j'ai pas tout à fait les mêmes
chiffres que monsieur rebeyrotte bon
nous qu'est ce qu'on constate au niveau
du gouvernement ce qui fait absolument
le contraire de ce que nous défendons
aujourd'hui ils taxent en offrir
d'alternative pour remplir les caisses
de l'état
et pour compenser la suppression de
l'isf et le manque à gagner du séisme on
n'a toujours pas de contreparties
sociales et environnementales et j'ai
envie de dire que l'athée icpe pour 2019
c'est 37 milliards de recettes qui
seront collectés et le gouvernement
aujourd'hui va simplement fait fléché 7
milliards d'euros sur les énergies
renouvelables coptes à bazar sur la
transition allergiques s'il 6,34 la
transition c'est pour les énergies en
réalité ce sur les mots que nombre de la
fiscalité écologique je parle bien des
recettes de la tei cpa des 37 milliards
seulement de l'étranger environnementale
enjeux écologiques du côté des
entreprises vous prenez en compte on a
fait il ya quelques semaines ici même
une émission sur le changement
climatique tout le monde était d'accord
pour faire des efforts à ce moment là on
n'avait pas du tout parlé de fiscalité
donc on a quand même l'impression quand
il s'agit de fiscalité c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué bien alors concernant
les travaux publics
nous sommes une profession qui avons
toujours mis en avant le développement
durable savais que j'en ai jamais
entendu une qui disait qu'il n'avait pas
mis un comme non non non non a donc
quelques vents avaient des faits
concrets puisque nous avons
afficher nos volontés dans le cade avec
nos entreprises qui devront au quotidien
nous oeuvrons pour le le recyclage nous
oeuvrons pour l'utilisation de matériaux
alternatifs
donc ça toujours été une logique pour
les travaux publics à vous utilisez du
diesel ont du temps du diesel on utilise
du gasoil pour nos jeunes chantier du
gasoil qui est des taxes et donc ça
c'est sûr on va être impactée
fiscalement donc c'est une mesure
fiscale et nous nous ne sommes pas
opposés au développement durable est
évidemment à la taxation sur l'écologie
c'est pas ça le sujet
le vrai sujet c'est la fiscalité qu'on
nous propose une une progressivité dans
les mesures fiscales adoptées
oui mais la brutalité de la mesure
fiscale
c'est terrible pour nos entreprises et
ça va nuire
bien sûr l'économie repart ça va nuire à
l'emploi et à nos investissements de
demain j'élabore à scénario peut être
malhonnête
si le gasoil et retaxer est ce que ça ne
vous poussera pas à demander aux
fabricants de matériels de trouver des
solutions par exemple des moteurs
électriques des hybrides que jusqu'à
maintenant personne n'a demandé puisque
le gasoil est en détaxe et vous n'y
aviez pas intérêt alors aujourd'hui
quelques engins de chantier qui se font
en hybride mais on n'est pas avancé sur
les matériels de travaux publics autant
que les automobiles ou l'automobile
aujourd'hui et plus qu'avancé de par
l'électrique et les véhicules hybrides
en revanche en travaux publics nous
sommes un peu en retard certes mais
c'est un travail que l'on fait avec nos
constructeurs au quotidien on a déjà
réduit nos consommations de carburant de
parts déjà l'évolution mécanique des
moteurs avec les constructeurs donc ça
on réduit déjà la consommation donc la
réduction de consommation agit pour la
planète et donc ensuite il faudra bien
sûr d
moteur alternatif et là dessus on y
travaille avec le constructeur revient
totalement vincent guinée vous ai dit ok
tout à l'heure quelque chose vous disiez
moi je suis dans mon village est ce
qu'il ya dans ce dossier aussi l'idée
que on l'entend c'est une mesure décidée
dans les villes pour les gens des villes
qui peuvent prendre les transports en
commun mais ça tient pas compte de
l'avis d'une partie du pays
c'est comme ça que vous le vivez est ce
que c'est ça qui vous a mis en colère
aussi aussi oui parce que il est évident
que je vais prendre mon exemple je pars
à 3 heures du matin de chez moi j'ai 17
km pour aller au travail
je me vois mal aller au travail en hiver
par exemple en trottinette électrique en
vélo à pied ou en roller ou ce qu'on
veut donc je suis obligé de prendre un
véhicule à côté de ça je le seul une
famille nous sommes 6 il faut
automatiquement un véhicule adapté pour
six personnes
aujourd'hui je ne connais pas de
véhicule électrique pour 6 personnes
donc ça veut dire s'il ya des aides
supplémentaires sur l'hybride par
exemple est ce que c'est parce que est
ce que tout ça est pas fait pour vous
poussez vous à faire le choix d'autres
choses ils savent où est ce qu'on peut
le comprendre comme sa survie j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y avait une aile de
2000 euros pour les foyers donc très
bien c'est bien gentil je l'entends il
manque 18000 euros
je les trouve ou je ne sais pas je pas
retourner à la mangue en a déjà des
crédits pour les maisons on a des
crédits pour les voitures et autres
deux mille euros c'est un peu se moquer
de nous rémy rebeyrotte est ce que ça
veut dire que dakota d'un côté on met
une fiscalité qu'on comprend écologique
en tout cas annoncé comme tel mais que
globalement on est pas prêt à proposer
aux gens quelque chose en même temps non
une alternative ça veut dire qu'on a
longtemps utilisé les carburants
uniquement pour une fiscalité d'
équilibre pour le budget et que nous
sommes en train de changer cela en
fléchant véritablement une grande partie
de ces moyens là sur justement la
transition écologique
alors il y aura des aides aux
particuliers effectivement pour pouvoir
acquérir franchir le pas on va sans
doute d'ailleurs encore les renforcer on
va avoir enfin les premières voitures
françaises hybrides parce que peut-être
aussi que nos retards énormes en france
dont constructeurs ont peut-être pas non
plus pris
suffisamment mais on les encourage mais
aussi aller vers le diesel à une époque
donc il faut vraiment qu'on amorce cette
transition là et c'est vrai qu' on ne
peut pas continuer à vivre et je
comprends monsieur en se disant tous les
5 10 ans va avoir une flambée des prix
du carburant et comment on fait pour y
faire face
il faut qu'on arrive à se dégager de
cette impasse de la flambée des prix des
matières fossiles et ça en rajoute une
couche sur le président des villes par
rapport aux gens des campagnes moi je ne
rentre pas là dedans c'est ce qu'on
entend beaucoup ces derniers jouaient là
dedans mais bon je crois pas non plus
aux côtés forcément spontanée de la
manifestation du 17 et je vois qui la
soutient lé voilà je vous fais serment
il vous avait annoncé semblement
nationale et france a soumises ont dit
très clairement qu'il soutenait la
manifestation bon voilà donc je je je ne
fais qu observer les choses
bon je dis simplement que il faut
ensemble que nous franchissions cela et
que l'on aide chacun je suis d'accord
avec vous à franchir ce pas déterminant
vers des économies une économie et une
énergie alternative c'est absolument
majeur pour notre pays
on s'y est engagé on y va faire mal
arlogis acadie dans son rapport à partir
de maintenant il faudra changer des
choses dans vos vies quotidiennes en
leur rapport ils disent ça et 10 jusqu'à
maintenant tous les pays ont pris des
mesures environnementales mais ça n'a
pas marché à part comme maintenant il
faut agir sur vos vies quotidiennes
est-ce qu'on assiste je vous repose la
question que j'ai posée au début de
l'émission mais je persiste sur pour la
première fois ce moment où c'est
peut-être les libertés individuelles et
la façon de vivre des gens qui sont
réellement impactée parce que jusqu'à
maintenant
finalement on sait jamais vraiment posé
la question je crois que si on aide les
gens qu'on les accompagne à changer
leurs habitudes pourquoi il y aurait des
réticences c'est ce que dit monsieur guy
n'est donc il faut investir et donner
les moyens aux gens de changer leurs
habitudes parce que évidemment c'est
inéluctable aujourd'hui on va dans le
mur
la l'inaction des chefs de l'inaction
des états nous conduit vers un
réchauffement de +3 degrés avec des
conséquences complètement inconnu sur
nos modes de vie et les clips des
écosystèmes donc je vais revenir sur la
fiscalité la fiscalité écologique ne
doit pas être subis elle n'a pas vécu
comme un
comme un fardeau pour les forces puisque
l'unique d'écologie punitive nous on
parle de fiscalité redistributive
et c'est peut-être bien ce qui fait la
différence entre nous et le gouvernement
aujourd'hui donc il ya des mesures très
concrètes pour faire ça donc on verra
monsieur ribeiro avec les 13 milliards
de collecte de la taxe carbone comment
elles seront fléchés alors moi j'ai fait
un petit calcul un c'est très simple on
doit déjà moderniser le réseau
ferroviaire
ça c'est un indispensable pour ça on a
besoin de 3 milliards d'euros par an
pourront collecter des années on a beau
dire c'est moi terminer parce que c'est
là qu'on voit qu'il ya des vraies
fractures
on a neuf mille kilomètres de petites
lignes on à 9000 kilomètres de petites
lignes qui vont être fermés car ils ne
sont pas entretenues donc en 3 milliards
d'euros à mettre en perspective de la
niche fiscale sur le kérosène que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure
donc là il ya moyen de trouver de
l'argent on doit s'attaquer aux 7
millions de passoires énergétiques
aujourd'hui le gouvernement mais un
milliard sur la rénovation énergétique
là où on a besoin de près de quatre fois
plus sur ce chantier donc vous voyez
qu'avec les 13 milliards qui vont être
collectées en 2010 9 de la taxe carbone
on a encore des marges de manoeuvre pour
massifier les transports en commun que
ce soit dans les villes ou dans les
campagnes de mettre en place des
indemnités kilométriques n'aurait pas
fallu le faire avant à bas les les
écologistes ne sont pas au pouvoir il ya
eu d un mystère que marc rappelez moi ya
pas eu d ministre écologiste et françois
hollande on est on est pas on n'était
pas en charge de ces dossiers dans
lesquels on est bien d'accord
vous voulez rien savoir oui tout à fait
en disant je suis très heureux que vous
fassiez allusion à aux travaux sur le
ferroviaire c'est évident il faut faire
des travaux ça donnera des travaux pour
nos entreprises c'est ça mais je crois
que là la bataille et l'est à deux
titres en premier lieu concernant nos
entreprises et en public ces de la
fiscalité net où nos résultats
d'exploitation de nos entreprises est
principalement nos pme tpe
il y à la brutalité gelé die de cette
mesure fiscale
il y a aussi le combat que défend mon
voisin vincent sur le le particulier
l'individuel ou là on a des salariés
dans nos entreprises qui aussi prennent
leur véhicule tous les matins et aussi
c'est une difficulté mais dans les tran
plus que je leur avais dit que les
entreprises pourraient peut-être et des
leurs alors mariée on veut bien aider
les salariés y a aucun problème là
dessus mais il faut qu'on ait quelques
compensations quand même on ne peut pas
être taxés on taxe en fait le l'économie
quelque part on va pas on taxe
évidemment le l'individu dont quotidien
mon tacle économies et on taxe aux
entreprises sans contrepartie garantit
aujourd'hui à un mot par rapport aux
parce que ça concerne la vie quotidienne
de tout le monde
le monde des travaux publics travaillent
beaucoup avec les collectivités avec ce
qu'on appelle la commande publique
la modification du tarif du gaz oil sava
signe ici ça va être quoi ça va être des
tarifs plus élevés pour vous ça veut
dire une commande publique peut être
moins importante parce que les villes
pourront plus payer autant de travaux où
justement tout cas c'est ce que vous
annoncez est-ce que c'est quoi c'est une
façon de mettre un stop ou c'est
vraiment vrai opposé à une hausse de
carburant je devrais pas être là dit
rémy rebeyrotte tout à l'heure on est
habitué un petit peu donc on l'a
toujours absorber sans rien dire
aujourd'hui à la hausse du carburant
c'est un phénomène mais il ya là aussi
la hausse de la fiscalité
ce sont deux choses différentes et deux
combats différents et la fiscalité
il ne faut pas que ce soit au détriment
de l'économie c'est ça ce qu'on
revendique aujourd'hui nous les travaux
publics et on a toujours fait on parlait
dans l'est dans les habitudes
quotidiennes
on a toujours essayé de valoriser nos
matériaux sur place sur des chantiers et
rémy rebeyrotte il le sait on a toujours
évité de mettre les camions sur la route
quand même quand on le pouvait et
utiliser des matériaux sur place pour
éviter justement de
de polluer davantage mais le vrai sujet
c'est la compétitivité de nos
entreprises
si compte tenu de la brutalité ce que
c'est soluble dans l'écologie ce n'est
pas ce que c'est ce qu'on entend souvent
c'est à dire que oui l'écologie c'est
bien mais il faut que les entreprises
soient rentables
ça veut dire que chaque fois on reporte
l'écologie mais pour finances et de
l'économie
le financier de l'écologie il faut
absolument qu'ils aient les entreprises
rentables dans ce pays si on ne
financera pas de l'écologie si en france
les entreprises ne gagne pas d'argent il
faut de l'argent pour financer
l'écologie ça c'est une certitude aussi
j'en suis convaincue nous reste 10
minutes d'émission il faut qu'on se pose
la question de savoir ce qui va se
passer dit entre aujourd'hui et le 17
edouard philippe a dit il n'est pas
question de revenir sur cette politique
fiscale qui met un prix face à la
pollution va sanguinet qu'est ce qui
peut faire que vous ne manifestiez pas
le 17 il faudrait quoi prendre des
mesures il faudrait où vous voulez
montrer quelque chose le 17 quoi qu'il
arrive à mais de toute façon il nous
faudrait je pansse un représentant de
forces de l'ordre par personne présente
parce que tout le monde va sortir le 17
je crois que le mal est fait même si
demain notre cher président nous dit on
mais le gasoil à 1 euro je crois que
c'est l'ensemble l'ensemble du pouvoir
d'achat ce sera quoi je suis l'agent
voyez ce sera on veut pas payer d'impôts
ce sera on reconnaît pas nos dirigeants
ce sera parce que derrière ça ça ouvre
beaucoup de voix et beaucoup de ce mode
de d'explications ou de compréhension
mais sur le nombre de citoyens qui vont
être dehors le 17 beaucoup sont d'accord
pour être taxés effectivement l'écologie
c'est très important
il faut être sensible
beaucoup souhaitent entre guillemets
payer des impôts on est d'accord mais
derrière faut arrêter tout nous piquer
quoi donc quoi qu'il se passe on va
montrer le nombre le nombre présent
dehors le 17 on sera dehors de toute
façon si s'il n'y a pas de mesures
prises
j'ai envie de dire radical parce que
c'est pas de nous blesser deux centimes
par ci nous dire on va vous donner 20
euros vin rouge
très sincèrement je n'ai pas besoin des
20 euros j'avais pas besoin de ces vains
l'euro la ccsa ces deux-là la poudre de
perlimpinpin comme comme l'a dit notre
président on sera dehors le 17 ça c'est
clair et net même temps l'augmentation
du prix en ce moment elle est à peu près
équivalente à sa non augmentation du
prix du pétrole
oui ça va ça va me faire sur un plein ce
manque encore des sous à la fin du moins
d'amis rebeyrotte vous entendez ça comme
un ras-le-bol fiscal en france vous
l'entendez comme quelque chose de plus
fort encore par rapport à la classe
politique on a ra à la dernière
présidentielle on a parlé dégagisme et à
un moment donné où ce type de mouvement
peut aussi ressembler à ça oui enfin
dans les propos j'ai cru comprendre de
la gav est quelque chose de très
politique pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas compris
moi je trouve qu'il faut rester sur le
fond du problème
le fond du problème je ne dis pas qu'il
ya une augmentation du prix des
carburants t il y avait 35 ans est à la
baisse mais qu' il faut absolument que
nous n'ayons plus des situations comme
ça dans notre pays où nous sommes très
dépendants du pétrole et de cette
énergie fossiles et renouvelables
les élus ruraux que vous est il faut
choix quand vous êtes à l'assemblée vous
dites quoi aller en vrai pas sur ce
plateau oui vous dites cette mesure là
elle va quand même nous mettre dans une
belle attendait cette mesure-là
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole c'est
le marché mondial du pétrole dont il n'y
a pas de mesure là si vous voulez sur le
plan de la taxation on est sur une
logique qu'on a toujours connu patriat
lui supplémentation du diesel c'est
ruralys id
non mais plus le faire ah oui mais
attendez oui sauf que ni françois
patriat
ni moi ni personne ne contrôle les prix
mondiaux du baril et c'est bien tout le
problème c'est pour ça que quels que
soient les gouvernements si nous sortons
pas de cette dépendance
il suffit de mesures pris par monsieur
trump concernant l'iran ou
d'autres problèmes qui peuvent se poser
d'un moment à l'autre dans les régions
fossilifère pour que nous ayons des
problèmes absolument majeur au plan
planétaire
alors il ya non seulement le choix de
faire monter le diesel c'est quelque
chose que vous assumez sur lequel vous
pensez qu'il faut parvenir à ben je
crois de toute façon de toute façon faut
tourner cette page là donc il faut
absolument faire en sorte il faut
tourner je le dis la page du transport
et du diesel et de l'essence
on entend en face de vous un sanguinet
qui nous attendent et on sort de la
logique a consisté à dire les sens c'est
moins bien que le diesel donc on
favorise le diesel aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que diesel c'est parmi eux
que les sens
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait là qu'est ce
qu'on fait en échec de dégager des
moyens pour sortir de ces logiques là je
le dis vraiment il n'y a pas d'autre
solution
parce que de toute façon jouer la
concurrence entre ces deux types de
carburants on a bien vu que c'était une
impasse car malheur c1
est-ce que c'est un tournant ou est ce
que c'est quelque chose auquel vous avez
du mal à vous associer parce que
forcément on sent qu'il ya une
différence entre vous on sent quand même
temps vous souhaitez que ce tournant
écologique soit pris comment se situer
par rapport à ce mouvement pour vous
mais nous c'est très simple il faut une
fiscalité écologique qui soit
redistributive on entend le malaise on
le voit parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
pas tous égaux devant l'énergie
il faut quand même bien constater que
20% des dépenses pour les ménages les
plus modestes les dépenses énergétiques
c'est 20 % de leur budget pour les plus
aisés c'est 6%
donc il faut bien redonner redistribuer
cette fiscalité écologique qu'on ne doit
surtout pas abandonner elle est
indispensable il faut des milliards
d'euros pour financer la transition de
nos modes de vie donc on attend vraiment
que monsieur ribeiro tu portes 7,7
indispensables changements dans le
budget 2010 9 et par exemple on a il ya
quelque chose oui mais on pourrait aussi
très bien passé les transports en commun
avec une tva à 5 5 % par exemple ça
c'est aussi quelque chose qui aurait
énormément d'impact
vous avez envie de vraiment ça marche
bien tout à fait parce que je le dis
bien je félicite ce que vous dites sur
le
le besoin d'investir dans ce pays mais
pour revenir ou mauvais interpeller tout
à l'heure sur la la conséquence pour
après la dépense publique et les la
commande publique
c'est ce que l'on craint nous dans la
profession une hausse de fiscalité on va
à le répercuter évidemment il va falloir
passer par voie législative ça va pas
être facile au niveau de bercy de
rédiger des textes législatifs surtout
un marché privé lorsque les prix sont
fermes et non actualisables mais ça va
coûter plus cher une fille née à la
collectivité
puisqu'on va le répercuter sur nos prix
est évidemment les budgets étant
contraints aujourd'hui nous allons avoir
moins de travail dans les années qui vit
à les jours c'est la fin de ce débat
merci à tous les quatre prochaines
étapes donc le 17 novembre
restez avec nous pour la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique
francis letellier reçoit marlène
schiappa la secrétaire d'état à
l'égalité homme-femme au revoir merci et
bon niveau
[Musique]